[Music]
the true self-conscious
existence which spirit receives in
speech which is not the utterance of an
alien and therefore contingent
not universal self-consciousness is the
work of art we met with before
it stands in contrast to the thing-like
character of the statue
whereas this exists at rest speech is a
vanishing existence and whereas in the
statue
the liberated objectivity lacks an
immediate self of its own
in speech on the other hand objectivity
remains too much
shut up within the self falls short of
attaining a lasting shape and
is like time no longer immediately
present
in the very moment of its being present
paragraph 713 is
very short and there's not an awful lot
going on in it in terms of development
but there's
an important contrast that is being made
which is going to play into
the following paragraphs they're going
to be consolidated
into what what hegel is calling the cult
in german the cultists
and what we're seeing here is
two different manners in which
language spraka or utterance is another
way of translating it here
they're both spraka and the german are
being
used and they're played off of each
other so
he says that the true self-conscious
existence which spirit receives
in speech in language in spraka right
which is not the utterance and here we
get a
sentence that's a little bit clumsy in
its construction that we're going to
have to clarify a little bit
so let's pause first on thinking about
this the true
self-conscious existence
so existence is design and that you know
that's meaning a being within
you know our experience the world right
and it's
true it's it's vara it's self-conscious
right it's conscious of itself
and of its relations to others so spirit
takes this on spirit has this capacity
within language
not just by itself not just say through
perception or thought
but through this medium that constitutes
language or hear speech
now the rest of it reads like this which
is not the utterance of an
alien and therefore contingent not
universal consciousness
is the work of art we met with before so
that whole big
clause there is a little bit tricky
not the utterance of and then you know
it's
neat right is in the german and all of
this stuff
is what it is not so hegel is
not saying that the true self-conscious
existence is not universal
self-consciousness that's not how you
should be
reading that little sentence there
he's saying that it's not and now we're
putting all these things into one basket
the utterance of an alien friend we've
seen this in the last three paragraphs
it's not the utterance or the speech the
language the the spraka
of alien and therefore al zou
right contingent zuffaliga
not universal uh nick algamina
self-consciousness so it's not the
utterance we might rephrase this it's
not the utterance of an alien
and therefore contingent
self-consciousness which would not be
universal
so once you read it that way it probably
makes a little bit more
sense i don't want to criticize miller
for how he's
translated it having translated many
things myself
but it is kind of a clumsy construction
that lends itself to some
some misunderstandings what are on the
book ends of that the true
self-conscious existence
is the work of art we met with before
and then he says it stands in contrast
to the thing like
dinglika character of the
statue builds zoyda now this is kind of
an interesting
word here because it does mean statue
right but it can also mean ornamental
column so there's a nice ambiguity here
in thinking about not just the the
statue in the middle of the temple
but maybe also of the architectural
features of the temple which are
static however dynamic they may be
in their design they are static in that
they
present themselves to us and that's why
we can go to ruins
of temples from long ago and you know
whatever's still left over
is still there by contrast
language is as hegel's gonna say it's
more like
what like time time itself
how so well language exists in time
but it exists in time in a way different
than
physical objects do you know physical
objects like statues you could say well
language is itself a physical object
yes it is waves in the air that's true
and you can write it down and those are
through the
media of physical objects but language
itself is not a physical object i'm
actually reminded here
of something quite interesting you know
the stoics who hegel
isn't talking about here and kind of
gets wrong earlier in the phenomenology
and he wouldn't know this really from i
think his studies but the stoics
you know they were materialists but they
didn't say that everything was
matter there were also the immaterials
and those included the lectone right
what what is spoken there's a lot more
to be said about that but
in any case language at least in this
passage
it doesn't have the kind of thingliness
that the statute does so what's the
contrast here he says
whereas the statue exists at rest and he
just says you know
ruined it doesn't he doesn't actually
say it exists
as such uh speech is a vanishing
existence now he uses the word daza in
there
and for fers right uh disappearing
vanishing how so well
i mean consider this we're recording my
speech right now
hegel has recorded his
language his spraka in the form of i
mean he didn't write in english
and he certainly didn't write in in this
kind of script he wrote in a different
kind of script
but it you know you get the idea it's
preserved
but when you're reading
you're moving from one word to the next
right
you can say well same thing with the
statue i i move around it i'm looking at
this side
now i'm looking at this side or i'm
looking at the head and now i'm looking
at the
feet or the base and now i'm looking at
the stuff in between
right the light changes the statue
changes its aspect
that's true but it's not the same it's
not even remotely close
to what language is like language is
much more like a stream
that you're in and it's flowing and
you're grabbing stuff
and trying to make sense of it as it's
going on
what did i say five minutes ago do you
know i don't know offhand
um you know there's there's all sorts of
things that are
vanishing away as we're using it and yet
it's
almost like a miracle that the sense the
meaning
in language remains as we're
talking through things so he says speech
is a vanishing existence whereas in the
statue
the liberated objectivity
gegenschtendliekite right being an
object lacks an immediate self of its
own
in speech this is a really interesting
thing to say
objectivity remains too much shut up
within the self
so the self is what comes to
dominate right objectivity
is getting itself lost within
the self and he says falls short of
attaining a lasting shape
and is like time no longer immediately
present in the very moment of its being
present
think back to sense certainty right now
now is gone by the very time that you
register me saying now that now is gone
and we've got a different now
and we can say that now becomes a kind
of generality
yes true it's an indexical word
addictic if you like but it only
functions by
not being where it's supposed to be in
time
and it's similar with language hegel is
on to something quite interesting here
that's going to be
talked about quite a bit by linguists
later on
in the you know late 19th and and
the 20th century he's not really going
to exploit that too much he's got
other fish to fry so to speak but that's
part of what's going on here
in this very short section
the movement of the two sides
constitutes the
cult a movement in which the divine
shape and motion
in the pure feeling element of
self-consciousness
and the divine shape at rest in the
element of thinghood
mutually surrender their distinctive
characters and the unity which is the
notion
of their essence achieves an existence
in the cult the self gives itself
the consciousness of the divine being
descending to it from its remoteness
and this divine being which formerly was
not
actual but only an object against it
through this act
receives the actuality proper to
self-consciousness
now in paragraph 714 these distinctions
that we've been making for the last
several paragraphs between
the statue with its thingliness
and objectivity gigan schenleykite
and language being used to
not just designate but also to you might
say enact
and provide a place for the universal
the self
these are brought together in something
that hegel
is calling the cult
and right off the bat i've mentioned
this before in previous videos
when we see this term in the 21st
century
in english we often think of particular
religions that are you know we we say
they're
cultish and what do we mean by that
they're kind of closed
in on themselves and they
suck people into their organization
don't let them get out exploit them
are hostile towards the outside world
put that aside
that that does not what hegel is talking
about here
the cult just means any sort of
community
of worship and we should say one other
thing about this as well that might
help you to to understand this so a
community of worship
in the classic sense is not
simply centering around
say the religion or the god
or something like that and you know oh
we're not worthy
we're just garbage you know here's your
offerings or something like that
if you actually look at religions
as their practice there is a sense that
the gods are
you know better greater there's
something going on there you have to
watch out for what you're doing
but there's also a sense in which the
community is
connected with that god in some way is
welcoming them or treating them like a
guest
or perhaps propitiating them like
somebody who could easily
lose their temper but you can in fact
work with so there's also this sense in
which
the the god is no longer totally
alien totally other as some people you
know like to
make religion out to be there's a
familiarity going on there as well
so he says the movement the vague
of the two sides or both sides the baida
right
constitutes the cult
a movement he says in which the divine
shape
in motion in the pure feeling element of
self-consciousness so we got one side
over here right
uh the divine shape the gestalt
in in motion we'll talk about that in a
moment
and then we've got another side over
here the divine shape at
rest the divine shape in the form of the
statuary or the temple whatever whatever
it happens to be
he says at rest in the element of thing
hood so what we've got here is
motion and rest being brought together
right
and we also have as he says elements
in the element elementa
of self-consciousness the pure feeling
and
findung in this case but it's also
linguistic as we saw
in just the previous paragraphs of
self-consciousness so that that's one
side over here the divine
is indeed self-conscious it is indeed
universal
over here on the other side we have the
element of
thing hood ding height he doesn't say
gegen stendley kite but he said that
just in the previous
paragraph so we could read that in
as well and these are being brought
together
right the movement of both sides and
what is the movement he says that there
is
here's where it gets really interesting
um they mutually surrender
their distinctive characters their
ways in which they are distinct from
each other
their particularities you could say they
mutually
surrender them to each other right
so there's kind of a fusion going on
here
or if you like he doesn't use the word
synthesis but we could call this
a synthesizing moment within the
dialectic
and then he goes on and he says this is
really important
the unity which is the notion of their
essence
achieves an existence in the german it's
actually a little bit
more dynamic he says that the unity
achieves an
an existence a dozen and then he goes on
to tell us
what this unity is the notion of their
essence the vason
right so we have essence and existence
and notion but
if all being brought together into this
in again a kind of unity now
achieving or coming to existence is
going to be connected with
another term that he's finishing up with
actuality
vehicle kite so many times we've seen
this arising
within the phenomenology haven't we that
whatever is there in essence or they're
in mere notion has to be brought to
actuality or reality or to existence and
then we know
what it actually is right so
he goes on and he says
in the cult the self gives itself
the consciousness of the divine being
descending
to it from its remoteness so that's one
side right
the divine being is descending to
the self and the self is
the worshiper the participant in the
cult the leader
of the worship service but also the god
who is there
as something self-conscious it becomes
now
possible to relate ourselves
to the god as another self-consciousness
not merely as the thing at rest or some
lord that we can't relate to in any
important way
and so he goes on and he says this
divine being which was formerly not
actual but only an object
over against it through this act
what act the act of descending the act
of
self-giving through this act receives
the actuality
now actuality of what sort the actuality
proper to self-consciousness what does
that mean
self-consciousness is actual by being
in the world by being related to other
self-consciousnesses by having a history
by having contingency
this is where the gods are becoming
more and more human-like aren't they
this is setting us up
for the section that is going to follow
we're still dealing with this in an
abstract way
but there's some pretty cool stuff on
the horizon
this notion of the cult is already
implicitly contained and present in the
stream of sacred song
this devotion is the immediate pure
satisfaction of the self by
and within itself it is the purified
soul which in this purity is directly
only essence
and is one with essence the soul because
of its abstract character is not
consciousness which distinguishes its
object from itself
it is thus only the night of its
existence and the place
prepared for its outer shape the
abstract
cult therefore raises the self into
being this pure divine element
the soul perfects this purification with
consciousness yet it is still not the
self that is descended into its depths
and knows itself as evil
but it is something that only
immediately
is a soul that cleanses its exterior by
washing it
and puts on white robes while its inward
being traverses the imaginatively
conceived path of works
punishments and rewards the path of
spiritual training in general that is of
ridding itself of its particularity
as a result of which it reaches the
dwellings and the community
of the blessed
coming on the heels of the two previous
short paragraphs what's going on in
paragraph
715 is a very interesting
in some ways almost digression
we've seen that the two sides have been
brought together
into the cult right the cultists
in german and now we get the essentially
the
abstract cult as he's going to call it
halfway through
this paragraph and he tells us
some really interesting things about the
cult
but what's more interesting is what the
member of the cult who he's calling the
soul right because
what is a person in religious terms well
their soul
what the cult is doing to them offering
to them is in a certain way a stepping
away from
what we've seen developed previously
and we're going to have to have
something restored to it so
this is you might say a presentation of
an ascetic path or a devotional path
that a person certainly can take but
it's also a bit of a misstep
so let's take a look first at what we
might call the
communal and more objective
side of this and then we'll talk about
the soul and what he has to say
about that so he tells us the notion of
the cult the concept the
grief is already implicitly contained
and
present it's it's contained within
what the stream of sacred
song now sacred song is a
use of language of utterance
shbracha all right so it fits in with
what we've been talking about
up to this point but it's it's more
determinate in a way
because it has been set to another
element that of music
and so you know the strong the stream
that's kind of a nice thing to talk
about because in a moment he's going to
be talking about purification
right and this strum could make us think
about you know river rituals
as well as a stream of music
and it's it's sacred song here is
translating
hymnation gazongas is that the right
translation
well it works but it's not like heidigah
or
anything like that hymnation in the form
of
hymns now who do you who do you do hymns
to
well to the gods or to god right we
talked about these hymns to demeter and
to apollo i mentioned some of them
a couple sections back and it is
song right so there's this devotion is
being displayed
through this and the cult is also
working through this he says this
devotion the undocked
is the immediate pure satisfaction
befririgong a term that we've seen come
up at a number of points
people want to enjoy people want to be
satisfied
and this is one way to do it in religion
and immediate
pure satisfaction now notice what he
says after this
this is going to get us to the soul of
the self
by and within itself
so there's a very complex self-relation
to self here isn't there
and that's going to get left behind very
quickly in this that reflexive
connection to one's own self it's going
to get subsumed
into the cult so he says it is the
purified
soul which in this purity
is directly only essence vasin
and is one with essence now what's being
left out what did we just talk about in
the last paragraph
actuality we talked about um
you know existence design and in
paragraphs before that we talked about
the
contingent the zuffaliga right all of
these things are being
set aside by the soul
of the devoted worshiper says the soul
because of its abstract character
isn't consciousness which distinguishes
its object from itself
it is thus only the night of its
existence and the place prepared for its
outer shape
what is the abstract cult doing it
raises the self
into being this pure divine element so
what we have here is sort of like a
fusion with a god or becoming the god
or relating ourselves in such a way that
we
lose track of who we ourselves are
the miserable contingent finite beings
that that you know have backstories
and aren't completely purified or
perfected
right and he goes on and he says
it is still not the self that has
descended into its depths
and knows itself as evil as biz
as you know something particular
something set aside
something that has its own drives
something that can be like singing in
the pews
and also having impure thoughts or even
just distracted thoughts
uh maybe even about you know what page
are we on in the hymnal or things like
that
um i am just talking about personal
experience and
singing in church or engaging in oh man
my voice sounds really good today
being prideful about that that's
gone that's being taken away and hegel
seems to present this
as if it's kind of a loss
isn't that an interesting idea hegel is
not an ascetic hegel is not a mystic
in this respect right this is what a lot
of religions promise and what a lot of
religious people experience
but it's not something particularly
great for the worshipper to not have
what he's calling
its own particularity right it says it's
something
that it only immediately is it's a soul
that cleanses its
exterior by washing it putting on white
robes
right so that's the ritual and you know
they're maybe
in a stream or something like that
ablutions
as well as dressing up and then he says
what about
interiorly he says it's inward being
traverses the imaginatively conceived
paths of works
punishments and rewards the path of
spiritual training
in general so you you know you think
about the stories
you think about how you're supposed to
be what kind of person
you're turning yourself into you know
what a great person
you are losing yourself the
particularity
of who you you've been in this new
perfected self within the abstract cult
and he says it rids itself of its
particularity
as a result of which it reaches the
dwellings and the community
of the blessed a whole bunch of other
people like itself
within the abstract cult
is this what religion is really aiming
for it's an important step along the way
something is being
achieved and attained in you know
mystery religions or in other sort of
devotional
practices right in the way many people
approach things
in the ecclesia or the church
but there's more there's there's
supposed to be more
going on so we're gonna have to look a
little bit more closely at what the cult
is actually providing and you know this
is a preliminary section
in this big part of
this portion of religion
you